how are you doing today sir you get a
million questions for you I want to
start with the I the the high frame rate
in this in my opinion is the best I've
ever seen in terms of the high frame
rate I enjoyed hobbit
I enjoyed Billy Lynn but this is like
next level is there a difference in the
technology or am I just getting used to
it you're getting used to it and also we
we're getting used to it we did better
it happened both ways Oh God hey take
the prisoners spectator some time to get
used to it like my eyes isn't beginning
to be different than now after five
years is quite different than usual eyes
it's just how we process information
you're our head that's a changing thing
I thought I used to say you can see for
yourself I don't I don't believe that
anymore we see something but we see it's
different so if I'm not mistaken there's
a 3d 60 frames a second a 2d 120 frames
a second they'll have a hundred twenty
4k was shot in 4k God and we have a 2k
flat version 24 yeah we have I have a
question
would you rather people who are watching
this interview would you rather them see
be 3d 60 frames a second or the 2d 120
frames a second of course in 3d got it
because that's what we're shooting for
okay when I translate into the 2d or
different frame rate after recreated to
make sure the the viewer has a phone
with it I thought that the 3d was
actually spectacular in this I'm not
always a fan of 3d I heard the rigs you
were using were the big cameras talk a
little bit about the challenges of
filming in 3d with this high frame rate
we have to upgrade our equipment or
change our equipment because we have
actions certain agility is required so
thanks to Irish the camera company they
made seven smaller camera for us where
we can shoe that 124k native and we have
to invent and develop through a German
company new 3d readings so it's smaller
a lot of new computer stuff so we can
accommodate to make an action will be
like this the the the technology that
you what you did to bring Will Smith
down it to be junior is incredible
we're what were the shots that you were
most can I guess what were the things
you were most concerned with in terms of
bringing this to life some subtle acting
of course because when it action like
actually it's not easy not easy but uh
the the part eyes concern the Mo's when
you have exquisite acting in this kind
of format close-ups that's when you get
nervous but at the same time will give
you the most material to work with to
because when he's in there we will
capture him with such great cameras and
some 30 scanners so he provide a lot of
information for you to work with it's a
it's a double-edged sword the more
you're nervous the thing you're nervous
about at the same time you have more
information to work with so it's no sure
I'm always obsessed with the editing
room because that's the final rewrite
I'm curious what did you have along with
your first cut of the film compared to
the finished film about 20 minutes
different was it like assembly stuff
where it's just like fat or with access
first Cod assembly is of course not EE
30 40 minutes longer right 30 30 at
least what was the last thing that you
cut out of the film before you picture
locked remember some expository scenes
[Laughter]
yeah is afraid if you don't have that
people don't get it especially this is a
mass entertainment but the idea they are
better without it
okay take it out sure did you move
better I'm curious did you how do you
feel about the test screening process
and do you feel that it benefits you do
you learn a lot about the movie when
you're showing it to people I don't like
it there's something I have to go
true but then of course inevitability we
learn something I like the movie to keep
it a secret a very private until here's
to you let me run away right but the
real world doesn't work that way after
all you make movie for for the audience
so that give you a test of what you work
with on the other hand not just the
movie how it will perform the most
valuable is do they have any reaction
that's in units and then you have to pay
attention or any confusion yeah not you
make adjustments sure this has been a
project that's been in development for
like 20 years or something how early on
had you heard about this project and
wanted to sort of go after it uh where
they came after me when they fell is
within reach and I I say you can do this
and that and I can go buy it so this is
all fresh to me it was 20 years for them
that write me about two years ago they
invited me to Davey Allison and invited
me to his office and then Jerry join in
yeah it was 20 years for them ten years
for them 20 20 years for the the project
but there's only two years for me it was
pretty new to me one of the things that
I found about David Ellison is he's very
passionate about making movies loves
movies what was it like cranberries uh
you know he's it has the Jing of of
science so it's very supportive from
technology
completely yeah um what one of my last
things is that what I'm what I'm
fascinated about with your career is the
ability to work in so many different
genres and they're all so great what is
it have you have you always wanted to
work in all these different genres or
have you ever been sort of asked hey can
you stay in this Lane do you know what I
mean it's not like I like different
genres I don't want to be locked by
genres but make a movie you you have to
understand shower because that's how
your audience understand movie
it's like a contract to them sure it's
Jarrah has the mind trick mind track and
then they're really established and to
do what you want to do and that's also
being locked and you sort of have to
break it a little bit that's why I was
hopping around a little bit so they
don't go certain ways and demanding
certain watch movies it's a hard thing
but it's this part of the freedom I
wanna enjoy as a filmmaker besides that
I'm habit films still deny like to learn
how this is fascinating I love making
movies I like to learn how to make all
those genres all those aspects and we
approach a new aspect you've you've meet
with the experts who can teach you so
much the career life keep my learning
alive and I enjoy it